[Music]
on the right
and do it right cause we coming at you
lots
[Music]
back at it again
foreign
[Music]
people on the planet he's awesome I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna we're talking
man Tears On YouTube if you haven't seen
it my God you're missing out yeah now
now here's the thing about me yeah dude
I want to start this podcast by saying
first of all congratulate me
congratulate me I had sex with my girl
last night twice now 55 years old
without Viagra having sex with your girl
twice and and Still Still rocking Still
rocking with McConnell twice or what
time we talked in here oh well the last
time was about that night yes sir so you
did that like right when he got in bed
and then did you wake up in the middle
so so so so I I watched House of dragons
what's got me going got me are you
updated on it
just about no I'm not all right so we
can't discuss it because of course I'm
definitely not gonna discuss it because
I I can't have any sport alerts from you
there's dragons so I I we I we we get
busy watch a little I'm watching dragons
I decide you know what these dragons are
getting me going but here's the thing
the flame here's the thing it's not that
the Flames fire turns me it's not that's
not what it is dude I am I go heavy in
the gym now dude my boy Nick who opens
for me Nick Simmons who's a uh [ __ ]
bodybuilder he's a bodybuilder oh yeah
he's serious about it he was he was
doing compete he was doing now he's a
[ __ ] comic really funny comic he was
doing he was doing military press
sitting down with 120 pounds in each
hand
doing this 120 000 that's a lot of
weight yeah true or false yeah you guys
can do that yeah of course military
press I could do like at my Peak three
reps okay so he he did six reps with
120. that's pretty that's pretty good
now you know it's a very thick yeah he's
short right he's short yeah about five
seven don't count okay I'm sorry keep
going can you do that with 120 yeah yeah
all day yeah all day yeah five seven
okay but don't don't be a dick because
the point is this is 120 was
huh no five seven guys long arms
okay but now you're here right now right
I don't like to hear I don't you're not
even letting me finish I know but I
don't like that you're [ __ ] poo
pooing 120 I can't I know it's
impressive if you're over six foot but
the thing is is you're here right now
and you said and he said bodybuilder
yeah
that's a bodybuilder no no no there's so
there's bodybuilders right there's
people that do it for a living and then
there's he likes Fitness he's a thick
Fitness he's been bodybuilding a long
time the point is I've been working out
a lot I go heavy now yeah and now that I
know
come on I go heavy now yeah and there's
something about going heavy oh boost
that dick juice it does boost your dick
juice you think that's what did it well
it's not only that my appetite but I
have
tons of energy but I'm [ __ ] I was
sore you've always had energy though I
know but this could this this revs me
the [ __ ] up so that is like heavy
deadlifts your dick's rock hard it's
just spikes that test well whatever I
was doing I was we hit back we hit
shoulders and [ __ ] I don't know you
do you break it up but twice a week I'm
gonna be doing that so if I get thick as
[ __ ] and I'm and I'm and I'm kind of
[ __ ] aggressive and in your face
that's why yeah [ __ ] yeah dude yeah
that's why because you're doing high
volume too like lots of sets yeah so
when you guys are talking about
weightlifting now now I want to jump in
I'm going to jump in you can meet us at
zoo yeah yeah come work out with us at
zoo because we'll work out Bradley
Martin who's not strong at all but I
like when you tell me about guys being
strong and then also you have Bradley
Martin you have Mark who's a freak you
have me and then you have a guy who's
commutes and strong men now I don't mean
like
no he's been doing since he was a kid no
no like legit makes money competing
strong men well now that's he's driving
down working out you guys are taking
plates off when you work out with him
you're taking plates off that would be
your workout sir yeah you'd be
oh dude you're gonna come right you're
not gonna work out with this right
because it's a waste of time well for
you but what you're going to do you
wrecker wins oh I'm not and that's gonna
be your workout I'm not gonna be your
weight record yeah you're you're a white
boy you're rack boy that's so insulting
hey you're gonna wrap your weights right
I'm not racking your weights I'm rack I
need some weight wrecker bro yeah yeah
hey bro I want to get in the
[ __ ] you guys
no you should I think this would all be
really like to have you come and live
with us to have a strong income document
it and me just be the weight record yeah
and then you can be sore it's been a lot
of weight you came 45s back and forth
over and over all day okay fellas I want
to load up five five you're like that's
ten aside I'm like I know it's gonna
take some time keep going now that's
what is that 4.95 what is that if it's
45 pound plates yeah 55 pound plates and
kilo plates so 25 pound plates or sorry
25 kilo plates at Zoo for example the
red when are you guys hold on when the
[ __ ] are you guys throwing five Wheels
on them [ __ ] on that will be deadlift
yeah bench I probably never will in my
life but
yeah are you benching that you trained
for it are you benching that no I can't
bench fight now you can take 120 in each
hand and and do military yeah I'll do it
for you tomorrow how many I don't know
we'll find out tomorrow he's a strong
gorilla a little bit of a gorilla
absurdly strong yes yeah weird for the
amount of like it's not like Brendan's
training for a bench press so I'm saying
I think if you train for three months
yeah he's got what I think you're strong
is pulling
I don't know yeah
that that strong man though he who came
to the show killed me agree he's like
I'm gonna he's like I was like come work
out with us he's like I'll drive down to
zoom and he lives out there I'm like you
don't know the drive but yeah come on
down that drive dude yeah it would be it
would be easier on my body if I did one
show in New York City if I took a plane
for six hours flew New York show jumped
on my plane back it beats on my body
it's true and we got an Airbnb because
you know I've done Ontario I don't know
four or five times now so every time we
would do the shows and drive back and
Jay's like it's killing us you get no
rest he's like let's get an Airbnb dude
we got this Airbnb I'm gonna send this
gin we hit this Airbnb in Ontario or was
that right outside like Rancho there was
donkeys everywhere
donkeys everywhere donkeys Burrows
boroughs everywhere see
when you drive that far do you calcify
when you get out of the cards you have
to kind of are you a little bit limpy or
no I'm okay if that hasn't happened to
you yet no no yes
I just take a picture of these donkeys
now I don't know if you've ever seen a
donkey in person they're not small Mark
you're way too close hey man that's a
live event
donkey will [ __ ] you up too that's what
I told him I was like they get a hold of
you man you're getting [ __ ] up what I
said Mark trying to grab this [ __ ]
thing it's two in the morning zombies
everywhere eating the lawn chewing on
tires
did you get protection I know how to
interact with animals I wasn't gonna go
I just went I let him come to me yeah
and smell me did you see that picture
that video on Instagram with the donkey
was dragging that guy around us the pen
did you see that no I'm sure uh Tim
bring that up bring up the picture first
and I'm telling you this was no small
donkey and there were several of them
chilling well this guy was hitting his
donkey and then look there's Mark
touching on the street that's our Airbnb
back right there what do you mean
there's just donkeys hanging out on the
street everywhere
I brought it up on are they wild donkey
yeah I brought up on stage and
everyone's like where the [ __ ] you stand
like bite the mountain like oh yeah that
makes sense Donkey sound there's like
Signs the signs say donkey there he is
what that's so [ __ ] thing a bunch of
donkeys there's several like every night
just friendly you can just pet him I
didn't
Mark you don't look like you're petting
him you're just reaching your head no I
we did touch I touched the dog his ears
are back so sometimes that can be a sign
of get the [ __ ] away from me I told
James me I just went like this and I and
I let him come to me I re I mean I took
the picture that's a screenshot from the
video the only reason I got the video I
was like I told you I'm like God I pray
to God this donkey [ __ ] markup yeah
then we go viral baby
you ever seen up the big black dicks
dude dude
I got donkey dicks dude right now that
that was a female I think that you were
no no that thing had it had a dick out
of there yeah yeah all right well unless
you know I don't know how what the hell
they do it but that's marking a donkey
yeah there's the Ontario just be that
that drive just beat you up because then
I stayed Thursday Friday got an hour of
sleep because if anything's off I can't
sleep these days at my age like the the
way they even be the master bedroom the
air would blow directly on you yeah and
it was loud so that kept me up and had
earplugs in so I was like all right well
I either turn that off then I'm burning
hot I can't sleep or I'll just deal with
it try to deal with it legit hour of
sleep Friday night 8 A.M alarm clock I
finally fall asleep about 7 A.M 8 A.M I
gotta [ __ ] go because Tiger has first
soccer game in Calabasas so I drive all
the way down like there's not gonna be
traffic from there at 8 A.M wrong son
yeah two and a half hours at least I
drive back at night yeah because night
it's like an hour and 12. that's the
move dude any sort of traffic any and
the thing is there's no accidents
there's no reason for it look there's
there's no reason there's never a time
with that drive we are not in traffic
for three hours you just have to be I
don't give a [ __ ] every comic that I had
that's why I had three cops on my opener
and I'd give this kid at The Improv uh
five minutes and then Trey Stewart who's
a Savage he's he just got past the cell
in New York Dave Luke's can't make it so
I use Trey when David can't do it so
it's Justin Trey and then the new kid
every single person out because they
they could have stayed at the Airbnb
yeah but they're like no I'm fine and
bring stuff I'm like all right whatever
every single one they walk in Grim just
broken that that for the reason that
drive just just because it's so ugly
that's broken I said I'd rather drive to
San Diego you don't see a tree I'd
rather Drive San Diego it's a pretty
Drive no no nothing dude I agree it's
you're just in you're surrounded by
Steel that [ __ ] with your eyes it [ __ ]
with you it stops stop and go stop and
go that's weird right I can't stand it
it was a fun time though it's a good
club Jen bring up the the donkey beating
the [ __ ] this guy's hitting his donkey
he's hitting his donkey in a cruel away
and the donkey goes you know that was
enough enough and watch what this donkey
does to this guy just donkey Fights Back
owner
donkey yeah donkey bites [ __ ] donkey
drags owner around I don't know this
should give UFC fighters inspiration
this is how you guys should treat Dana
White over forcing you guys to wear the
rock shoes this should be inspiration
because this donkey's had enough you
Fighters have had enough
take inspiration from this donkey
fighting back man yeah it's a donkey
it's a donkey they have dull teeth
they're undersized [ __ ] where is it I
don't know where it is but it's great
I mean dragging them around too
and the guy owns the donkey yeah
let's take a little break from me and
Brian count chatting about whatever
[ __ ] we're chatting about when we
take this break because the NFL action
is in full swing we're talking about
week three baby and you can watch the
NFL and make bank with draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL we talking touchdowns
big plays even bigger wins new customers
can bet just five dollars on any NFL
team to win and get 200 in free bets if
you do that's not enough say less
everyone can boost their winnings with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
right now for every leg you add you can
boost your winnings up to 100 percent
with payouts bigger than ever why bet on
football anywhere else if you ain't
doing DraftKings you're not doing it
right to make things even sweeter you
can throw down on stepped up same game
parlays once per game day all season
long download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app right now use promo code fighter get
200 in free bets if your team wins when
you place a five dollar bet on any
football game that's coach fighter only
yeah draftking Sportsbook an official
sports betting party at the NFL minimum
age eligibility restrictions by C show
notes for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer download
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
promo code fighter that might be a
donkey
this one I don't know
the thug received Instagram after
threatened to knock a donkey out
ferociously attacked I play that once
for the fact of it
oh they're no punk do
this oh wow
is mine
donkey up why would you want to hurt
that point oh I hope this donkey
why would you hurt a donkey yeah I
wonder why I wonder why it's not a thug
you should say dumbass receive Instant
Karma what a cute dog I was trying to
give him beer I don't want to hurt a
donkey they are cool they're mini horses
they're so [ __ ] cute owl bit my
finger yes yeah signed to back away
dude
I was hoping this happened to Mark ah
dude
because I was petting a donkey yeah
that's a good friend
oh [ __ ]
that's that devil donkey man dude don't
[ __ ] with donkeys I'm Tony dude that's
scary bit him right on the leg Yeah did
they ever abuse an animal you can shoot
me in the head but no I don't think they
may not have been abusing him I think
the guy just fell in that that guy just
[ __ ] up falling into the donkey stage
well but that but to Mark's point though
the goal was to punt knock the donkey
out oh so that donkey can feel I didn't
want no attention you feel the energy
yeah that's the city like horses donkeys
know your intentions 100 so they're
giving them bear they're hitting them
like he bit that guy it was like Hey the
donkey was like what are you trying to
do yeah so that bite was kind of just an
intro like back the [ __ ] up yeah homeboy
Falls in it animals like that are
already they're they're animals are prey
so they know when a predator is there
yeah
yeah and to Mark's point with that
donkey Mark was that like it's not
aggressive at all towards it he put his
hand out the dog he was actually pretty
nice yeah so I think they can feel your
intention it's like Avatar you might
want to be connected to the braid the
slippery this hey the slimy all I want
to do yeah dude Avatar you ever heard
the Avatar Blues
you know people commit suicide after the
first avatar that was 20 years I can
kind of believe that because people oh
it's real well people like when I saw
that I was like I remember just kind of
dreaming that how you'd never want to go
anywhere else that's incredible to be in
that [ __ ] we're headed that way we're
headed that way I have a virtual are
they called The Avatar Blues people
legit commit suicide now clearly
you know if they would have opened up a
pack of Starbucks and got all yellow
they were committed to a side so this
gives an excuse right so obviously
mentally unstable if a movie Avatar well
I can understand that that movie uh
sends you somewhere people were hard on
that movie and I was like I I thought
that was an incredible movie it was just
a remake of FernGully but so many people
were like ah that was [ __ ] that
script I go oh no I thought it was great
it was great I thought it was a great
movie that's a movie when it's on I'll
watch it every time me too well
especially I watched it in 3D did you
see it in 3D yes sir of course that was
the one that was like the first three
was it the first 3D movie is that how
old maybe I think that was like the
first big experience it was probably the
first one like that when it come out 2
000 it's 20 years old I saw Jaws in 3D
2002 no it's 20 years old
come on just part two is coming out 20
years later I don't believe it hey James
Cameron Could you hurry up 2009.
yeah 2009 not 2002.
still it's a hot second ago and then
part two's coming out I don't know in
December this year is it yeah it's it's
based off the water I guess
oh so it's they're in the water and [ __ ]
oh wow well it's called aguatar yeah I
don't know aquitar that's also yeah it
should be the plot of my time it's just
a little mermaid that'd be sick but
that's where we're headed with like meta
and stuff right now meta looks like [ __ ]
but eventually in 20 years after our
baby
so if you have your avatar Blues hang in
there daddy that's the the larger
question is where does where does
um virtual reality
take us in terms of like how much can it
replace physical sensation especially if
you're in a room where you're getting
the physical sensation oh like with
girls like virtual girls all of that
that's for sure coming but I'm talking
about so so if you now with virtual
reality you can actually see what it's
like inside a refugee's tent
so when they're trying to raise money
they take rich people and they go just
come here and then they'll have like
you'll be in a tent and there's smoke
and stuff and they'll actually put that
they'll create that so they get a good
person viewing and you're it's a 3D uh
experience a virtual reality experience
of what it's like you can go through a
bizarre you can go into a city and
really see what that city is like and
it's it's pretty damn close to Alaska
but it's not but it is yeah it's not no
but it is that's gonna be the same
they're gonna get there right now it's
not but here here's here's what I'm
saying so I went on Safari and I was I
was there in South Africa and I saw
animals okay problem was that I saw
lions and I saw giraffes and it's all
cool to see them and listen to them and
move and they're right in front of you
when I grew up when I was a kid in the
70s and I went on Safari in Kenya it was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I've seen and
Augustine so many nature shows so many
close-up [ __ ] that you go well they're
not doing anything those lines are just
lying there I've seen Lions [ __ ] jump
in the air grab a [ __ ] I've seen
everything yeah so it's kind of like and
so I really wonder if as kids who are in
the inner city and they don't have any
money they get to see what it's like in
downtown Bombay in every detail with the
exception of the smells and the noise I
understand there's a difference yeah but
man you can get you can get pretty
[ __ ] close yeah
yes twice Jesus Christ twice remember I
lived in Saudi Arabia I lived in
overseas so you Africa was so close you
could fly to Africa in an hour or two
and you'd be in Kenya and or more than
that but same like when you went the
shark diving like Shark Week where
they're showing the great whites jump
out of the water and if it ain't at that
level so so again what are we doing it's
like my my brother-in-law my nephews
they put on the the gear and they got in
the cage okay but we don't know about
those things is the cage is attached
it's right there the cage is always
there the boat just comes up of course
and the Sharks all know because they're
going to be fed and then I knew there
were no great whites there are other
sharks but I wasn't going to get wet and
get in the water so I could see them
from there I could see them from the
boat unless it's a great white I'm not
gonna do it yeah if it's the black tip
I'm out dude yeah matter of fact give me
my money these were bronze Whalers nope
give me my money back I agree if it
ain't a great white give me my [ __ ]
money back dude
great I want you to Chum the waters a
lot of extra blood all right trim the
waters let's get this thing really
aggressive popping yeah I want you to
attack something me too I wouldn't mind
it doing that thing where you saw that
guy removing that stupid glass box
stupid guy sure do sure he just died
that's what I see but that's what I'm
looking for that's what we're used to
well it's just we're coming desensitized
to all this [ __ ] like even when we see a
fight because the UFC and stuff like
that it's like Jesus Christ the first
time I saw UFC it was so brutal I was
like holy [ __ ] now think about now how
desensitized you are totally nuts that's
what happens when Wars happens but even
the news is even more a little wild west
of the stuff the show well it seems like
it's seven striking everything to show
that yeah people are getting a major uh
Target that we took out they'll show the
drones right I know from like the weird
you know angle but still someone died
right there it's [ __ ] weird man isn't
it weird yes
so weird keeping my son off YouTube and
away from that stuff at 11 those kids
will look at everything oh yeah they
know everything oh yeah it's like [ __ ]
yeah yeah YouTube the iPad it's [ __ ]
tough dude well also it's taken think
about celebrity we we can all remember
when celebrities kind of like you were
like damn I wonder what it's like to be
those guys like you know like you'd see
five minutes of them on on on some talk
show that's it that's it right if you
saw him at a restaurant oh my God sexy
and Bigfoot right but now
like like I remember when Arnold
Schwarzenegger back and and Stallone in
their movies we were like what the [ __ ]
exercises are they doing yeah how are
they shredded what diet how are they
lifting weights when muscle and fitness
when you see those guys all of us would
go gotta start doing flies if you want a
chest
description yeah I dude in sixth grade
seventh grade I got my hair cut in a
flat top
I had a I had a flat top and I wanted to
be the size of Arnold my mom told me to
drink milk yeah
get me still if you had found out that
they were doing steroids who would have
been like them saying they were gay yes
taboo nobody said no one did stare what
like even bodybuilders guy said doing
doing a bodybuilder competition one of
the first times was like in the 90s he
said being in a bodybuilder competition
without steroids is like being a beauty
queen without makeup and that was a that
was all news that was trending like what
they do stare why now nobody's even
gonna write an article no if it was like
breaking news an Olympian uh Mr Olympia
bodybuilders on steroids there's not
even an article not even an article it's
strange how far we [ __ ] come
well what does that work with like so so
then so here's my question they they say
that all of that's being taken out every
text you've sent everything you've ever
done anywhere on your phone anywhere
they're they're gonna have digital
archivists digital archivists who your
grandkids can find out who you really
were well hey grandkids if you're
watching us I apologize for those dick
big yep your dad's aggressive sometimes
all of that is the way we were if you're
watching this in 30 years
I'm not weird oh well everyone in here
was doing it man I was a product of my
time but then
that's deep fake [ __ ] but they'll be
like no dad here's the signature yeah
here's the fingerprint well even I I was
thinking about this like I drove down
tiger had his first soccer game he's
only practiced twice I'm like this can
be a [ __ ] show but as we're driving I
told Jay I'm like hey pull up uh
Cristiano Ronaldo highlights so he can
see the very best do it so Tiger's
watching that before the before his game
I'm having to watch Christian uh Ronaldo
highlights and messy highlights of
course he's like you know when I was a
kid you you'd watch Maybe Junior Seau
like I'd watch you know some videotape
VHS or whatever to get ready for the
game I guess but not like hot you'd
watch like jock jams I'd listen to Jock
Jam some [ __ ] to get hyped for the fight
but or for the game but then I had tiger
watching Ronaldo and he's watching it
was Hey Dad and remember he's never
playing the game he goes hey Dad so I
can it's legal to do that uh scissor
kick where he flips and does the kick I
go what he was Dad can I do that scissor
KO
technically yes you could [ __ ] do it
you just need to touch the ball too
you're not throwing a [ __ ] fight kick
but said eventually you're gonna get
there I went he's a black belt in this I
said he's been doing since you're think
about the fact that he has that in his
head oh but even gold that's what I was
thinking I was like oh he sees that now
so that's a possibility and he's like
Dad I see him using his head to head but
anything you gotta go again he can do
that he's been doing it since he was
your age he's been doing it for 30 years
dude I said I just need you to get close
to the [ __ ] but to your point you
have kids now that are 11 years old and
younger who have the exact same stroke
as Roger Federer exact same stroke
because they grew up watching oh his
best friend his dad played uh Pro in uh
England and he he's on like a traveling
team like the competition team I was
talking to the coach about him because
he's uh T's best friend and I said hey
uh Joshua he didn't come and goes excuse
me and I go do you know Joshua is yeah
he came out here for one of the practice
he's on like the uh
he's not like that he's first of all
he's six he's on the 10 year old 12 year
olds team and he goes he will score he
goes he'd score 50 goals if he plays
with these kids because we can't have
him out here wait wait wait my son's
best friend Joshua he's really skinny
real thin kid but just he's that good
he's just Savant he plays non-stop Ty
came home from school last week and he
was in a bad mood like what's wrong with
you dude he goes at recess Dad we're
playing soccer and Joshua lined all of
us up and uh told us to stop the ball
and I go what do you mean lined audio up
he goes there were six of us there and
he scored every single pack when I go
you couldn't stop one he goes no and
then he told us who he's gonna put it
and I was like no I was like Manny how
old is he he's sick oh no I go oh man
he's flexing on you guys but also like
hey genius well you know my mom is a
mother he's a freak and then to that
point though Tiger goes hey Dad uh
Joshua's dad will buy him a toy if he
scores a goal so that's why he goes so
hard during the game against a girl and
tigers never played a game before I go
okay T if you score a goal I'll get your
toy first man of the game
boom swag I guess I'm like oh [ __ ] and I
was crunk I'm like yeah
my mother was talking I think to the or
maybe she was listening to this the
person that uh at Juilliard Juilliard is
the school in New York where you know
it's it's the most prestigious School of
the Arts yeah it's a big time Japan went
there
yes I believe he did it's got a pedigree
yeah you know it's like I think in fact
Rob Williams went there correct for a
year and then they're like get out of
here but but but but
um so so the guy was saying now when we
have singers
or you know musicians because they have
YouTube because they've watched the very
best every single one of them 15 years
ago if any of them have even come up to
they all would have gotten in they would
have been total standouts now
everybody's amazing Everybody by the
time they audition are so technically
unbelievable they're just on a different
level like they're we don't even know
who the [ __ ] to choose it's literally
like well I'm enrolled but that's
everything because the level and people
have exceeded expectations for what you
can do in sports you look at basketball
football if you go to a pop one or game
now or middle school game now you'll be
Blown Away really and everything
wrestling basketball football soccer
baseball like my uh uh brother-in-law is
a coach for uh like a little league team
and he watched the the traveling team
there's the high school kids and he got
there early and was like what is this is
this are these Pros are these callers
and they're like those are the high
school teams like what in the [ __ ] he
played High Level Baseball in college
he's like what in the [ __ ] well you like
now kids are doing you know year round
they're specializing in sports they're
playing 24 7. and the the the Gap that
they're closing the Gap yeah and people
are so they're so I think it's the wrong
thing to do but they're so specialized
in that injury repetitive injuries no
not not injuries they're just kids get
burnt out yeah they're [ __ ] sevens
but then also like I was talking to that
kid who's a savant in soccer I was
talking to his dad like hey how often
he's like dude I have no time to myself
Josh was practicing Monday Tuesday
Wednesday game Thursday game Friday
sometimes this game in San Diego on
Saturday he's like I have no I have no
down time [ __ ] and I was like is that
how he grew up yeah but I told him I
said if my kid was as good as soccer or
whatever sport he is as good as Joshua's
that makes sense yeah but if he's just a
guy no we're not doing that dude that
ain't happening yeah if he's just one of
the Average Joe's on the team yeah but
this kid he's the next he's the special
yeah that's a whole different thing well
tennis almost none of the kids that are
nationally ranked Under 12 become Pros
because tenant they just burn out yeah
they [ __ ] burn out you have to let
them do a whole bunch of other stuff
you know because
a lot of that's like that all these
specialized sports but now recruiters
whether it's D1 these big time colleges
and even the NFL they want a guy who's
doing wrestling baseball they want to
work well-rounded yeah they want more
well-rounded and have different assets
you know yeah 100 I think that's kind of
part of life yeah being able to adapt
and learning everything is the whole
point and being good at you know other
sports not just focus on one because
again they're worried about burnout yes
I think one as you're older getting
really good at one thing is how you
learn about yourself there's there's no
doubt it's probably the best way I love
when people go I'm going to find myself
where are you going you're just gonna
backpack around cool I understand you
want to see the world you're going to
change your diary if you really want to
learn about yourself [ __ ] like try to
get really good at something difficult
That's My Philosophy yeah you'll learn
what'd you bringing up too are you
brought up uh for some reason I guess
yeah I can't find enough but so sadly
the last Theodore who's been on uh big
brown breakdown before uh he passed away
from liver cancer
dying piece too
he did uh you can't find his last post
yeah down I'll find it no it's a
beautiful post that honestly somewhere
and you can't find it no not on his it
was a
something he wrote before he passed away
because he knew you know it was getting
bad God man can you imagine facing
the [ __ ] death at its doorstep and
you're 34. yeah
dude
but yeah I'll get you I'll find it yeah
I'd love to see it handsome [ __ ]
too huh dude he was the first man uh
ring card
dude [ __ ]
it's horrible man it's just in 34 liver
cancer did yeah and he fought pretty
recently I think about last December
really yeah dude
yeah I don't know it's just one of those
things man when it's time to go it's
time to go and that's [ __ ] terrible
yeah that's kind of like one of those
things where you go no way I didn't
believe it when someone told me that
they're like you know he passed away
like what
I'm dealing with that right now the
friend of mine is 38 the same thing it's
38 yeah it makes no sense and what's he
have
no he he has angioso Carmel he's a uh I
just keep trying to call him but he's
not answering and unfortunately so so
and is that is that uh terminal
well yeah it it affects very old people
and for whatever reason he got it and so
did I tell you this is look at the draw
so so he was he was limping wait he was
my dad's caddy he's but he's became a
part of the family really close like to
all of us taught my kids how to golf was
always there the kids were going and but
he's also became just a friend because I
he's you know just became he was on the
tour he's a golf a pro on the tour
and uh funny and great and um he started
limping and uh my mother was like what's
going on because I my damn psoas you
know I can't couldn't golf you know he
said Pro you know and he was training
for the tour or whatever
and then six months later he's still
[ __ ] limping and my mother my
mother's like a witch and a good witch
my mother goes what's going on with that
thing and he goes ah it's funny is it
getting worse and he said it's just it's
not getting better and she's she looked
and she says well that doesn't make
sense to me
so he said yeah whatever another three
weeks go by she says you need to go to
the doctor and he says it it is they're
going to tell me I gotta repair and she
goes get an MRI he says no no I'm I
don't I can't afford it my mother says I
will pay for it they take them all of a
sudden boom he's got tumors he's got
these crazy tumors in his hip
and so he's really really sick he can't
even get up and then this woman calls
him this doctor because remember doctors
now all over the world talk to each
other they they do all this they
communicate and the doctor [ __ ] calls
him up and says hey it's like two in the
morning this Asian woman says there is
this experimental treatment that's shown
really good results with your kind of
cancer
so he [ __ ] gets on there and he
starts he takes that therapy and it goes
away completely my father who has a lot
of cancer doctor friends and stuff like
that my father
is he kind of just looks at me and I go
you know it's gonna he's got this
experimental therapy it's going to be
awesome and my father is just he just
looked at me I go what and he just goes
nothing just you know don't get your
hopes too high because no matter what
that therapy is man it just a lot for
now it kind of runs its course
so he's you know I don't know what's
going on but it it comes back it comes
back it came back so he came back yeah
and I'm sure this is the case with this
it's sometimes dude it just happens and
you're [ __ ] and you know you just
gotta oh well
you know yeah Cancer's a [ __ ] but we're
getting closer and closer the um the
kind of function the kind of progress
they're making on Childhood Cancer is
outstanding it's crazy so yeah for
Theodore and he's also a guy who was a
big Advocate with CBD and marijuana
because she was like painkillers [ __ ]
that man oh wow yeah he's huge in the
movement of marijuana and CBD for that
stuff start and just a funny guy like
really really a huge career outside the
UFC commentating and doing whatever the
[ __ ] God was he was he Greek or American
did he have an accent he's Canadian oh
okay he but he had did he have an accent
not really hmm
stud at such can't find that dude dude I
don't know what the house what are you
looking for it's like he he wrote this
message like a poem before he passed
away I saw it somewhere like I think on
Instagram
but not on his Instagram no well let's
try one more time on his then God did I
ever tell you did I ever tell you a
story
my my dear friend uh we did a [ __ ] oh
God we did a she died but we did a
benefit for her because she had cancer
and she got up and and the it was going
too long at the Laugh Factory and she
started making a speech and they had to
turn the room over they had to
he started playing music
and she thought that over her God damn
that's amazing Savage I was like oh God
that's [ __ ] heartbreaking man yeah
it came out of nowhere either
well it makes no sense when you're that
[ __ ] good looking and that special
you know I mean you just look at this
hair dude come on man you think you
think Luke Rockwell's good looking go
back so it wasn't liver chance it was
colon cancer oh he was the official that
happens
once if you're at stage four colon
cancer you're in really you're in real
trouble because it's see it metastasized
it goes all over your body colon cancer
incredibly incredibly [ __ ] curable if
you get it in time and the first thing
they ask is do you have any history of
colon cancer in your family and if you
do get a [ __ ] camera up your ass
because they can fix it 34 what do you
what do you do man
well unfortunately it's for whatever
reason he probably didn't get checked
early but why would you 34. why would
you man why would you have a phenomenal
shape
and you don't feel it and you don't feel
it our funeral's a little old school too
like my I have to go to Denver because
my grandma passed away and they're
having a funeral and all that stuff this
weekend it's a chance for people to come
together around you what would you what
do you think it's more of a party when
you die and you're gonna die before me
because you're so big 100 I mean not to
get you know and I I'm sorry about that
what do you what do you want what do you
want me to do
um do you want me to just cremate the
[ __ ] out of here have a party do you
remember the Improv or laugh fact you
have a party should I snort your asses
them on to everybody that'd be cool I'm
down for that yeah
I'm really frustrated you can't find
this I'm more free I think it's real
chin because it would be everywhere
right did you imagine it dude I know
you've always been impossible was I just
drunk or something because it would be
it would be every yeah last post would
be everywhere I'll find it and if I
can't find someone help me find it is it
not on Twitter
maybe maybe I don't use Twitter so I
didn't see it there yeah trust me it
would be everywhere especially it was
really heartfelt I know I know that's a
bummer yeah we'll see if we can because
how would you get checked you know you
just don't know so by the time you
attracted to do it so when you you yeah
you don't you don't know you do not
[ __ ] know until it's too late so
that's why like if you have a history of
colon cancer get a [ __ ] colonoscopy
and I don't care what the doctor says
just get it done because if they find it
and you have stage two curable as [ __ ]
very curable they just remove the colon
part of your colon you're fine
you're totally fine you know my dad was
saying that uh what you don't think
about like you know he's been my dad's
one of 13 or whatever you're one of 11.
there's a million cousins too which I
haven't seen I'll have to see him this
week but my dad's saying well you don't
think about when you pass away
he has to deal with all the allocations
of for money like figuring all that out
he's been a nightmare man nightmare yeah
nightmare but how's your family tree I
feel like you're all healthy
uh I mean it's diabetes in the family
but not cancer cancer doesn't
cancer I mean my grandma and grandpa and
my mom's side died of lung cancer but
they smoked yeah but outside that no I
feel like your genetics are good yeah
nothing because you don't you don't uh
you've always stayed in shape you've
never not worked out yeah that's the
whole family too everybody's my grandma
even until she passed away was swimming
every week really non-stop how old was
she 98. oh Jesus Christ yes I mean you
always say you're going to die early but
I I don't yeah we'll see I don't think
so my dad is a [ __ ] Giant and he's
82. doing the damn thing and that guy
could give a [ __ ] God how about the
funeral service for uh the Queen of
England do 12 days today they're finally
uh putting her down longest reigning
monarchy 70 years near Western people
are like throwing shade at her like okay
okay what do you want to do she didn't
choose she was thrust into that
Limelight at 25 years old where you have
to be perfect yeah but but even if you
look back at the whole
you know all that stuff the way when
countries took other countries over the
where slavery started Africans selling
other Africans like she's part she's a
[ __ ] in the machine she couldn't have
stopped it I mean
slavery was not it's not unique to
America everybody it's you know to the
human race other native Native Americans
would uh African other Indian slaves
Comanche and the Apache excuse me
I mean they're everybody the Africans
Europeans slave so slave the term comes
from sloths love the Slavic peoples were
always [ __ ] uh they were always
enslaved because they didn't belong to a
nation-state they were tried to another
nation state would be like oh we can get
those people over there hot girls and
use men for work the ones who were broke
they turn them into slave slaves slavics
slaves yes yes yeah and then in Africa
who do you think was putting those
slaves on the boats well in the interior
you used other Africans yes in fact in a
lot of the wars they would take captives
because it was money yes yeah that's
what human beings do to each other
slavery runs deep in all faster and it
runs in the Bible everybody in the Bible
in the Old Testament you never heard
what's amazing to all Scholars you never
heard the great moral thinkers from
Socrates Aristotle Jesus Muhammad uh
even the Buddha talk about slate the
evils of slavery that was a recent thing
the first people to really bring up the
evils of slavery were the essentially
the Evangelical Christians of Britain
the what you'd call right-wing
Christians of Britain back in the 1800s
did you they were the ones who started
the Abolitionist Movement look it up see
what's going on with the owner of the
Phoenix Suns they're trying to get them
out of there he owns the team and I mean
the stuff where he should be thrown out
with which is thrown on the radar you
know his sexist comments and sexual
assault stuff but they're saying that
really they want you out there saying
he's racist right of course but he would
listen I don't think it's the
appropriate thing to do especially being
a billionaire owner of the team but what
he would do is he would quote other
black guys using the n-word so it wasn't
his original quote he would quote what
black guys would say say it back to the
players yeah and people would tell him
behaven you can't talk like that and he
would say stuff like uh and now
you know one of the problems in the NBA
the criticism they get is so you have an
entire black team but you have a white
man coaching right that's a lot of
criticism that NBA gets well he would
hire a lot of black coaches he'd say you
would this is me paraphrasing him he
would say I need a ninja to coach these
other ninjas he was quoting somebody
else but he would say the actual word
around the players yeah but does that
make him racist and are you making the
world less racist by getting rid of him
I want to know are you actually do these
people actually think they're making a
difference and making the world more
Equitable and equal by getting rid of
somebody like that somebody who's not
doing somebody who employed like not
like majority black men and also would
hire black coaches which is the biggest
criticism in the NBA you're talking
about a guy who did all that even though
should he have used that words no
probably not because he deserves the
question is are you making the world
better by getting rid of their goals
publicly Shameless if I know you're not
but here's the problem they're going to
because LeBron of course the woke LeBron
who I can't [ __ ] stand now comes down
goes that type of behaviors we have no
room for it in this league so once the
pressure from LeBron who makes the NBA
moves comes along and then also PayPal
who's the big sponsor of the Suns was
like we're out if he's still the owner
we're out it's three million dollars
yeah exactly so they're out because
they're woke [ __ ] but then that
billionaire like all right PayPal's out
I'll just how much is it three million
I'll pay five million a year because
they're paying three millimeters to
respond to the team that billionaire he
could easily be like all right that's my
bad they want him out of the oh yeah
they want him out so he's spent it for a
year can't attend games
so his punishment he got a 10 million
dollar fine Kim 10 games spent for one
year for using the n-word yeah but
quoting for quoting it it's not
nothing's original and the other thing
there's like Donald Sterling right there
was record of that right so he was
[ __ ] Donald Sterling might have
actually been a racist but we have
actual record of it there's no actual
proof it's hearsay well I'll see he
hired a lot of black coaches right yeah
yeah
again you're you're my thing is that
you're fighting you're you are
pretending to do something for a problem
that you [ __ ] actually aren't helping
and you don't really care it's virtue
signaling look and also I love when
people are what's it called uh
chronological snobs you you'd be exactly
or Worse the same way as anybody you
criticize in history don't act like you
wouldn't have been racist or own slaves
yeah you would have because you didn't
have the benefit of history and
Charlemagne said he get too is a black
man he goes it doesn't sound like I was
racist sounds like he was trying to be
down with the black guys that he was
trying to be cool and just missed the
mark yeah he's like I don't think and
he's thinking there's no recordings of
it he's like it sounds like you're just
trying to be down but he would hire all
black players black coaches which nobody
else is doing come on you want to kick
this guy out oh man I don't know if I
said that good yeah I don't know if this
is the fight you're looking no it's but
it's it's not oh they get him out of
there once
he's [ __ ]
the LeBron puts pressure I constantly
Miss he misses the Mark he's not
educated on it it's unbelievable the
same guy says I don't feel safe in
ballet okay so let me ask you guys I've
been down below yeah but let's talk
about streets if you're dealing so so
okay so perfect so you're dealing with
uh so you want to make the world better
cool now do you get money from China or
do you [ __ ] with China in any way and I
understand if you do because it's a lot
of money
Space Jam so please please understand
your shoes please understand that the
Chinese with with the uyghurs and we've
already talked about this they put a
[ __ ] they put a an official in the
home of a uyghur couple to make sure
they don't have children and they live
there so is that cool are we good with
that China slaves as we speak yeah
they're enslaving people as we speak
yeah have you heard Lauren say anything
about that I haven't but hold on so do
the the Chinese people that are being
enslaves those uyghurs are do their do
they not count like of course
okay if I'm getting this straight you're
saying LeBron James is a hypocrite look
I'm not I'm saying it's very hard to be
consistent in this world I think it's
like I listen to [ __ ] Rogan and Seth
Dillon talk about abortion on on the
podcast and they got into it
yeah he's he's the editor-in-chief of
the Babylon B and he said well abortions
are really it's a human issue [ __ ]
messy you find yourself looking the
other way well when when is the when is
it murder when is it not it's all
[ __ ] it's like oh it should be a
woman's life no matter what I don't give
a [ __ ] it's not that good well I agree
with you it should be a woman's option
no matter what but he's men passing
these laws but it's not you should stay
out of it not just men and I and I hear
you but it's a religious issue so a lot
of people well Life Starts at conception
it's on its way to be a human being when
you stop it it's murder it's cool that's
it cool if you're religious do that then
that's what you believe in but you can't
force these other people who aren't in
your religion to do what you think is
best they can because because they are
saving a human life and that's how they
look at it what I'm saying is it's a
very and then you get into this okay so
you're saying a zeitge goat or whatever
the [ __ ] it is where it's just a clump
of cells what is that in comparison to a
kid is seven months old well that's why
we don't have late-term abortion we have
the the line was always when is the baby
viable outside the mother's body and
that was the thing but Roe v Wade was
overturned so now States like Texas call
it the heartbeat law the minute I can
detect a heartbeat which is after six
weeks or whatever you can't have an
abortion well you don't know you're
pregnant until a lot of times now now
and here's my other problem with it when
they say that you that you don't make
exceptions for rape or incest that's
insane what and and so you what about
the kids a middle schooler what do you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
insane yeah
my joke is this if you it's not even a
joke if you really care about The Unborn
worry about the born who don't have
parents is your house an orphanage do
you have one room that you dedicate to
fostering children well I'm just asking
I'm just asking well that's your problem
well that's like uh Kamala Harris she
was like we don't have a border problem
and then the like Texas who's having an
influx of immigrants goes oh cool you we
don't have a problem pamel Harris let's
do this we're gonna but we're gonna
[ __ ] put all these uh immigrants on a
bus put them in front of your house
that's what they did it's hilarious and
so now notice Chicago New York those
these states Vineyards yeah yeah these
states that go we don't have a problem
Texas and some other states are shipping
the immigrants up they go all right we
don't have a problem then you deal with
them yeah oh is it a problem but it's
not a problem because we're a red State
you think we're fine but when you're
calling us racist yeah when it's in your
backyard how are you feeling now and the
New York goes the the terrible Governor
there who used to be the chief of police
Adams goes well the mayor he goes yeah
Adams goes well if they would just give
us a heads up we can't handle this no
hold on I thought you were all the same
energy
so you're fine as long as it's not your
state and you don't have to deal with it
and deal with on a daily basis now you
guys have to face it it's not all good
is it and that's what Texas is in
California is dealing with non-fucking
stocks if two million [ __ ] people
coming over the Border because it's a
free it's open board yeah that's right
I have a buddy who's in the drug
business and he's like oh because the
board is open like there's just a
surface of drugs he's like everybody's
making money well he's like too much
he's like no he's a surplus of drugs so
people are sitting on heroin and
Fentanyl because and no one has money in
America because inflation he's like so
we're just sitting on it so he's like
now it's Spain in Australia notice the
od's in Spain Australia really that's
the new markets wow America's not the
market anymore really because they open
up the floodgates so everybody's coming
in so the Market's just oversaturated
America don't have a ton of extra money
spent on drugs so there's no business
it's interesting easy there's no
business here it's Australia Spain it's
Coke and stuff is so expensive in
Australia is it so why here you know I
have friends in Australia who are like
oh they come to La they're like Coke's
so cheap here I'm like is it they're
like yeah we paid 200 bucks a gram and
you know in Australia because the
difficulty of getting it I had a guy say
to me a guy who is a fan he goes hey do
you ever do any toot I go I didn't know
what he was saying what do you mean you
know you go I'm like what do you mean he
goes you know if you want to do I mean
if I got we but I got below and then he
goes like then he goes and this [ __ ]
comes straight from the cartel I'm like
oh the murderers oh that means there's
fentanyl in it is there blood is there
any blood that's mixed in any innocent
blood just mixed in with the [ __ ]
hard pass
yeah you gotta be a [ __ ] do Coke these
days with the fentanyl I don't know if
that it's not bad it's just like I
always feel like what is that where is
that where is that how many people died
to get this [ __ ] key
yeah well but using the iPhone I could
put that aside yeah no it's the fentanyl
the fentanyl are they mixing Coke yeah
hold on hold on hold on I don't know
it's a myth no you do let me see there
was some recent ODS probably from people
you know you know in the in the comic
Community well I remember that but that
wasn't they don't think that was okay I
don't know it was it's fentanyl now that
was fennel but they it wasn't okay wait
oh what was it
that was cocaine uh no I mean fentanyl I
mean fentanyl cocaine is my assumption
these days is any white powder you give
me you know this has fentanyl it's
inadvertent and B and that's why they
they they're telling people they're
giving out free tests they can test the
cocaine to see if there's actual cocaine
or fentanyl in it you gotta be more
under cocaine these days you know what I
always literally rolling the diet I
check with my [ __ ] uh my dealer I go
is there any fentanyl on this and he's
like no I go
I trust you sir I believe you hey guys a
guy I don't know is there any fentanyl
in this cocaine that's what killed Mac
Miller fentanyl he bought the cocaine
but it was like fentanyl [ __ ] so he
didn't mean to kill himself no not at
all and they arrested the guy who sold
the fentanyl because he thought it was
cocaine opiates still make like they'll
press pills to look like a Vicodin yeah
but it has fish I gotta stop doing
cocaine in the morning
dealer sentenced 17 and a half years
from his Roland Mac Miller because he
sold them what he thought was cocaine
but was actually laced with all fentanyl
because fentanyl is so much cheaper to
get so they can they can cut the cocaine
with fentanyl because fentanyl is so
strong so they're getting more profit
out of it so there's so much more of an
advantage to do a lot about it bro
what's up with you man I watch too much
[ __ ]
I'm gonna try cocaine I have no desire
to do it don't ever try it yeah you're
gonna do it after this I got some pure
straight from the cartel and the cartel
wouldn't lie to me I just don't feel
like doing it Schultz is talking about
his podcast like the one time he tried
it cocaine he was like yeah he was
talking about because he went to Burning
Man she'll say I did all sorts of drugs
how about on brilliant idiots and he's
like I did cocaine The Hangover is awful
he's like I get the same effect just
doing the Adderall yeah I don't always
just doing lateral I felt fine the next
day they see that cocaine I felt off I
don't think there's any upside to doing
cocaine
yeah you go you'll start a business and
be like wait I came up with the idea of
coming up with a candle shop that sucks
wow we don't candles dude why don't we
make scented candles and it will have
there we'll make them bigger than normal
camels there has to be someone who's
who's able to do it pretty regularly and
just operate on at a high level I'm sure
I mean you know Robin Williams lived on
cocaine before Sigmund Freud the great
Sigmund Freud who came up with the idea
of a subconscious change that came up
with the edible complex you want to have
sex with your mother [ __ ] everybody up
[ __ ] the entire all of Christian
Europe
cocaine he did enough as as uh [ __ ]
uh Robin Williams yeah Goodwill Hunting
said he did enough cocaine to kill a
small horse because he had he had jaw
cancer he had really bad jaw cancer and
so for whatever reason to start doing
that yeah remember did see the
Knickerbocker show with Clive Owen and
they portray him they're just like oh
he's doing coke and heroin and Coke and
heroin yeah because it was normal back
then like people it was like a classy
thing
it was in Coca-Cola it was medicinal
it's like it's like with the acid when
they first discovered that oh one drop
oh that's that's what I try cocaine if
they put it back in Coca-Cola if I could
get an old school Coca-Cola that'd be
fun drink it yeah hell yeah all right
Jim what do you got buddy up
couldn't find that a Theodore thing dude
I must be tripping unless hopefully
something this weekend yeah to be
everywhere I was looking for it too I it
might have been just like you know there
someone put a poem together with it like
that picture and wrote it because yeah
something about a life ending I could
have sworn but I can't find it literally
anymore it would be all over it feels
like that kind of heart you know
groundbreaking would be all over
all right
um what should we start with let's see
hold on a second here
oh
what happened
well there you go oh wait so the car
Falls it's everywhere I mean dumb way to
die [ __ ] that have you seen this guard
fall no okay
painted yeah but it's hot it's I guess
because it's been this long like fewer
like for hours and hours and hours right
people people have been waiting days in
line just to see the Queen's casket
keep watching who's he at which one
middle black guy in The Middle on the
very same swing yeah I can see him oh
right smash his name behead him for
disrespecting the queen how's that work
yeah he's [ __ ] he's super oh he's an
older man
he probably locked his legs probably
didn't eat right that day probably
nervous
just face right to that that was so
crazy and then no one else can move
hell no man yeah so that was pretty
crazy and some guy tried uh rushing the
Queen's casket and just got lit up
really yeah yeah oh no no don't do that
this guy's doing furry hats why was he I
know they look like stats chomping at
the bit to get active nothing ever
happens for him you don't see a lot you
ever seen the one where there's because
they're not supposed to move or talk and
some like American was like check it out
dude they can't do [ __ ] he's in his face
and he's like poking at him poking him
he's his face and the guy just goes
knocks him out
I actually didn't see that what do you
call them what are they called Prairie
hats are they the Queen's guard are they
called the Queen's guard or are they uh
hold on
I think we're gonna go for you they
might be the Queen's furry hat
one of the Fluffy Hot guards called
there it is
called beer skin a type of Serial
military no but I mean they are cool
yeah they are called else so they're
just the Queen's guards yeah and they
have to have the the assignment a chin
strap that's a bottom lip strap yeah and
that's bare skin hopefully holy [ __ ] but
they're called it's called what was
khabib's head
oh my gosh no his uh I forgot what it's
called
my guess would be wool
but yeah I don't know what they'll look
they're what European guards are English
called the Queen's guard the Queen's
guards right how many of them are then
what's the compensation
because those boys
that's the King's Guard
yeah
King's got her infantry contingents
while the king's lifeguards are Calvary
Troopers
so yeah there's just military and they
get
allocated that and it's gonna stand
there
yeah
that's not uh that's that's tough is it
the best gig for them either are they
excited about it when they get called up
to do that you just staying nothing
happens my buddy Mike Glover who ended
up being like a Delta guy and all that
but he started at 18. as a guy I think
he was a guard of the unknown the Tomb
of the Unknown Soldier in DC and you
have to do that inspection like the
whole and then he came we'll go to my uh
go to Mike Glover's Instagram Mike
Glover he was 18 and then he became a
high level I mean badass in the Royal
Army no no in the American Army was he
standing there with those guy he was the
equivalent in America of what we are we
don't do that [ __ ] yeah we do yeah we do
the Unknown Soldier keep going doing
Craft survival and he and and in the
first time there he is back when he was
in like you know honestly and did you
see the gun where he doesn't yeah
that was where but he was uh he's a
great [ __ ] guy but he he
just said he just he just picked it up
right there yeah he just goes we watched
it already I love that [ __ ] though but
uh so he would stand on guard like the
Royals yeah so you do it's something
similar yeah it's the best yeah Dime
Piece [ __ ] big boy I'm trying to
think we're we're where we do that I
guess the CIA like kind of stands up
front with the president we don't have
those weird hats on so Mike Glover real
quick with uh with Tim Kennedy since we
we have a connection Tim Tim was
um he they kind of wanted him out when
he was a in Sniper school for Special
Forces or whatever you want to get him
out they kind of yeah he was the guy
didn't like him and for what so Tim I
guess didn't have a spotter for the
sniper thing and and he said well you're
out and he said unless there's anybody
in this in this group who wants to
volunteer to spot for Tim but if he
misses it was like a thousand yard shot
if he misses you're out too
right so he these are all these people
and Mike Glover didn't even know Tim
goes I'll [ __ ] do it
that's why they're so bonded that's cool
yeah Mike got up and [ __ ] spotted for
him boom perfect shot but that one shot
if Tim had missed that shot he would
have been out of Special Force could you
even go as far as to say you only get
one shot one shot one kill bro this shot
this is your chance to blow he's gone
Eminem
well that is what it is now have those
Royal Guards ever had to really jump
into action I can't I've never I don't
think I've seen them yes do anything I
believe they have
you don't hear a lot of no
real Royal Guard collapses
guy tries to fight Royal Guard let me
see that I want to watch I'm sure that's
fine or else this spider will cry okay
not the spider
I love this [ __ ]
why are you such a dick
it's eight minutes you have to fast
forward son I don't think we're gonna
show it I bet they do at the end
Watch What Happens that's what we're
trying to do
those boys don't [ __ ] around
yeah I don't see it anymore
oh here it is they're big boys too
nah
Oh weird
click bait there's nothing
no not a single fighter I've seen
wow that's a terrible video
all right maybe we got another one too
just move on I don't think we're gonna
find there's just one a lot of them
collapsing though
yeah let's see times they fight back
oh [ __ ] it's fine they got his hat off
what the [ __ ] is going on here
pieces
I would [ __ ] why would you [ __ ] with
them I remember that oh [ __ ] oh this is
gonna
have a knife on the front I'll [ __ ]
around
oh see he's [ __ ] put you're not
allowed to touch him oh okay you have
the the
bayonet Band-Aid on the front
oh
that wasn't a good punch but that was
real bad did the job God
ah
yeah what is this now that's just some
random doing in there jumping on them
[ __ ] douchebags yeah right I don't
[ __ ] do we can see this punch again
like he actually pushed him right
it's like a slap and I wonder if that
guy is there any repercussions I don't
think so if you're [ __ ] with them no
you can just stand there you're you're
becoming a threat and you touched him
yeah that's a tough gig [ __ ] touching
Royal Army all right we'll sketching I
saw Rogan post this uh China was able to
discover some uh Crystal on the moon
that apparently
you can do nuclear fusion with for
Limitless energy oh wow it's the same
kind of power that powers the stars in
the sun that's crazy yeah it's a Rick
and Morty episode well the [ __ ] moon
is going to become a [ __ ] Battle Zone
then for Mining and [ __ ] hell yeah yeah
hell yeah [ __ ] yeah hell yeah [ __ ] yeah
bro we're gonna have space wars right
now
I mean we do have four pounds of rocks
yeah that was pretty interesting though
space wars let's go to Marx right now
that's very interesting
top to bottom yeah all right these are
all just bangers dude they're bangers
okay oh McDonald's life yeah this guy's
about to go uh break this ice oh [ __ ]
with his arm
[Music]
oh
his arm's broken his arm's broken but
he's good oh I didn't see it let me see
it oh my God he's all
oh no dude how did that happen how did
that happen he's all holding it up let's
see that again in an instant replay
come on dude yeah let's see him break
the arm the first time
this is his elbow
oh
how painful was this what's the pain
level right now can't be good somebody
getting some come on dude
get me out of here get me the [ __ ] out
of here get me the [ __ ] out of here
right now
okay Jesus Christ snap this [ __ ] arm
what's this I don't know
oh okay
of course Mike Evans has his back
yeah Tom's going through some [ __ ] right
now him and his girl Giselle she's uh
moved out of the house damn I was just
caught crying in New York I thought it
won I thought she was just to go back to
him you know what how about this they
that was a long run that's a long
[ __ ] run that's not easy oh yeah
they're talking about their marriage
yeah yeah so congrats on there's also a
long run from him to hit yeah I thought
you were talking about that marriage
yeah what sucks the NFL is going to
suspend Evans I bet a few games would
you would like would you in that same
position somebody's going up to your
quarterback 100 yeah yeah but you still
got to suspend Evans in a way no you
don't yeah you're fine no you got to
defend well you can't have that though
otherwise everybody I'm so [ __ ] these
days what else you got okay so this next
one is this yeah close up uh if you
didn't see it Brian I don't know if you
watch the fights for this weekend but
this is song your dog's cut we can see
that up close just how bad it was before
they stopped not a good cut yeah they
let it go on for a little bit
this was against Corey sanhagen yes yeah
did he win because of this he won
because of that he's a monster they
could have they could uh if it wasn't
for the cut it was tied two rounds a
piece on the judge's scorecard on that
fourth fifth round of course anything
looked phenomenal yeah he looked great
did you watch the uh Canelo uh Triple G
and me too born yeah well just I think
it was just time for a triple cheese
you're 40. and then he wants to fight
bivoli and he really didn't fight like
Triple G I figured there's no feeling
out process flat 24 rounds like let's go
and then he turned on the ninth round
but I think every time you throw that
you're getting [ __ ] boom but um
people uh he wants to fight people I
know he's out of his mind too big
here we go
so this is uh post Malone trips in the
middle of the stage you'll see the stage
is really set up weird like there was a
hole in the middle of it that didn't get
covered up and I assume you guys have
broken ribs before
they're awful they take forever to heal
because
it's hard a lot right so you're trying
you're sitting there going like ah I'm
in painting like ah ah ah yeah it just
depends there's a video of it see what
happens so he's just walking the stage
probably the highest [ __ ] and oh there's
a hole in there what the
oh
damn right so somebody's getting fired
for leaving the house
did he come through there life through
it it's like close that bad boy oh [ __ ]
oh somebody's definitely losing their
job that's awesome imagine how hard you
have to fall to break and that that
doesn't I mean that's bad that didn't
have to happen oh it's like because he's
drinking or smoking where the [ __ ] no
yeah age design yeah [ __ ] hole Jesus
Christ oh yeah and you gotta sing is
that him leaving it is a now Herbert the
starting quarterback for the Chargers
also broke three ribs this past weekend
which and he'll still play through it
but damn he will dude it's true breeze
bro he'll play he'll play oh yeah you
broke ribs fighting fighting yeah yeah
how do you how do you play through that
just shoot yourself up with something no
just played through it oh God it's so
painful post Malone he shouldn't cancel
any dates well no because when you're
singing though yes you got to breathe
there's a lot of pressure on them
ribs he broke them first game one MVP
the NFL was getting constantly hit he's
saying that's brutal get up I think they
get up in that thing though you know but
also I think things different and
there's no and there's no drug testing
you can take cortisone shots all sorts
of [ __ ] are you saying shut up and sing
yeah
so it's like Drew Brees I thought you
couldn't breathe in no you can I mean it
sucks it's uncomfortable but you know
seeing right yeah you're senior right
holy [ __ ] this is crazy my buddy sent me
this he goes this is too intense for me
literally a phone Boost oh he got
knocked
oh my god oh he's out cheating off on
him yeah and you can't stop it oh my God
hey I know
this is not an entertainment damn come
on man enough's enough yeah this is not
it but it is entertainment well I mean I
like to see it as a clip and that's it I
wouldn't like watch the entire fight box
they start back to back
that has to be Russia it's pretty badass
100 right you see all the [ __ ] Mass
Graves they found in [ __ ] Ukraine
from Russia and torture chambers no I
can't take it oh man hundreds of people
hundreds of discovering hundreds of
bodies tortured yeah so what they're
doing is I know this they're coming in
again if you're not if you're in that
town you get killed they're killing
everybody in those towns and and that is
a that is coming from the top clear it
out and then when we come back we that
that is what's going on in Ukraine
[ __ ] horrible
and the women are getting raped by
finding bodies of women children men and
then they're tied up and then they're
also they can tell they've been tortured
too so that they're torture chambers
they found torture chambers and mass
Graves Jesus Christ that's not good
Jesus Christ beyond what people can
imagine
what is this so this says uh the woke
waiting for Joe Rogan to say something
insensitive I just thought this was
funny
looks like Brendan and Theo if they met
a bed bath
oh my God
we need to repost that on King this
thing and put this out Brennan theater
this is awesome this is in Europe 100 by
the way dude I've been out though man
this is in Europe I got on the left is
[ __ ] wildest he's the greatest
they're both the greatest the greatest
what is this oh there you go so this is
just a silly goose time that's genius
this guy is taking his Goose for a mid
the goose this is walking we're flying
though it's flying he's got a harness
and it's flying that's genius
that guy that's a great way to get
attention he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
that goose but no he's getting a lot of
attention
he's doing for the grand how you meet
people that's how you meet people it's
like that guy who walks around with a
[ __ ] uh with a boa constrictor at
carnivals they've seen people girls dude
at the car show before they cancel
Malibu son of a [ __ ] but they uh
there's this girl who drives Lamborghini
has a parrot on her shoulder I'm like is
the lambo not enough you gotta put a
[ __ ] parrot on the cars and shoulder
yeah and then there's also a guy there
who takes pictures of cars with snakes
all over his hands yep my son always I'm
like [ __ ] get over here no I don't just
think don't trust together also that guy
is just deleting the in the Lamborghini
that's convertible like bright pink
Lamborghini yeah like that's not enough
attention you gotta put a [ __ ] parrot
on your shoulder well there was a there
was a bar there was a I'm sorry a coffee
shop in venice where if you were sober
you know you would hang there it was a
place where people had really [ __ ]
their lives up and it's where a lot of
those people would gather and I remember
when I was not working as an actor and I
was just [ __ ] just nothing was
working out and I walked by and there
was this dude and he just kind of was a
little overweight and he had a [ __ ]
parrot on his shoulder and he was
drinking his tenth cup of coffee
and another thing when I was an actor
and I just was like that could be my
future that could be that's how this
movie ends that's how this [ __ ]
remember when Eli did that show in
Oklahoma that time like I had a just a
pet snapping turtle yes I do and there's
just kids everywhere like well
dude the snapping turtle was as big as
your torso it was so big his head was as
big as your head for real why it was an
house
he'd pay for him you'd pay it pay like
whatever three dollars and he'd lift the
turtle up you know he'd put a pen put a
[ __ ] license plate and then the
turtle conk and snap the [ __ ] out of it
that was his whole gig and then it
pissed on the guy oh yeah all the way
down it's like arm and leg he's like
yeah it happens all the time because you
have to hold it like this it was just
like pissing down his legs that's cool
it's like 150 pounds 150 pound Turtle it
was huge and they're so powerful and it
was a real hit I mean he got our
attention
away from it no I paid three dollars
[Laughter]
yep I was like sweet trick man
stuff like when you go to um Mount
Rushmore the roads are littered with
stuff like that for the 90 miles of
nothing it's like you know snapping to a
reptile Farm pull off you get to me
every time yeah I'll tell you what Tim
McGraw I'm not really interested in
seeing him fall off the [ __ ] stage I
don't care this is more just a warning
to Brendan because a lot of people are
commenting on how tight your pants are
these days oh is this Thai pants oh so
Tim you're my age let's not let's not
wear a tank top that you tuck in oh he's
in great shape though I would do the
exact same thing no you wouldn't though
oh you can wear it such a good shave
because I would throw you in a flying
headlock let me see this
Oh Oh see it's the tight jeans that did
it yeah oh you might have been drinking
at least didn't take a real stumble dude
his act in 1883. he's good he's good oh
he's good have you guys ever seen him
live I love Tim McGraw songs yeah I saw
him in Wyoming it was awesome oh [ __ ]
yeah Tim McGraw just some hits
yeah his band's amazing too can't be
this vain at your age though I don't
like that shirt
apparently his workouts were like
legendary and I don't care don't give a
[ __ ] it's my [ __ ] face I go for six
hours right he does seem a little buzzed
huh hell yeah why not there's a bunch of
chains on and [ __ ] congrats dude
hold on to that vanity he's drunk as
[ __ ]
no I get embarrassed no I get him back
off podcast stop talking about your
workouts well that's true and compared
to Timber right but I'm not wearing I'm
not wearing a stronger right I'm not
wearing it
you know this take it back oh no no hey
[ __ ] that we know for a fact just take
it back okay bring up his workouts hey
hey I don't give a [ __ ] you think you're
stronger than him I think I'm better at
everything no no no he not see his
workouts hey I don't give a [ __ ] I I
I'll tell you you don't give a [ __ ]
Tim McGraw yeah and I don't either so
don't tell me I'm not in I don't think
you're making me mad hey I'm sorry dude
take it back now how old is he chin
he's like 56.
hold on he's looking good definitely on
trt and ain't you yeah
really yeah but he looks at me he's my
age he looks good that's a great body
that's why people poop oh so I don't
give a [ __ ] not looking like that
yeah no that's impressive now can I look
like that
he's he's natural yeah because you're
lean enough you would it would you know
that's that's what the Striking Distance
of somebody who you oh he's built he's
built like a brick [ __ ] house
no no listen having said that and having
looked at that I want to say this
I'll beat him at every sport shut the
[ __ ] up and and I'm still not hearing a
piece but I do appreciate how he looks
more athletic I don't think he's strong
yeah maybe not but I still think it's
literally all he does yeah but he looks
like a workout Capper the guy looks
great I just think he looks fantastic if
you see me doing that if I'm on trt and
I will be soon enough and I start doing
that I want you I want you to just
without warning just just take me out
mid tackle me so my ribs get hurt and I
can't work out anymore so you can feel
the broken ribs yeah because I just uh I
get him I I
know it used to be like overweight or
what no but he was big I should have
picture him his face just looked more
full so I guess he was going to start on
the scene he was like drinking beer and
[ __ ] he did a movie I forgot what it was
but he gained so much weight it was
insane look none of us want to get old
none of us want to be you know I get it
I get it God bless you should Rage
Against the night I work out I try to do
it but
there he is everyone's fighting father
time he looks good there not really look
oh my no wow look at the difference okay
he is hideous all right Four Christmases
that's the movie you know what happened
he got excited with the progress he was
making he he's reached he looks his best
he's he's realizing his potential yeah
his schedule's not more powerful there's
a whole documentary on it look at John
Favreau that's an awful
shirts
he struggled with some real weight
issues yeah
good director a great director boy Tim
McGraw it's awful there they both look
awful yeah
Volvo got a [ __ ] chin on him huh yeah
yeah well so that's a Tim McGraw and
father yeah that's pretty much it you
got to go do Adam Carolla dude oh [ __ ] I
got it yeah be that one you'll be fine
yeah I'll be good you'll be good
Pasadena I think yeah it's weird because
he lives in well I guess he owns that
studio but he lives in Malibu they moved
I thought he lived in La Canada or
something he used to he got divorced
okay dude talk about your divorce it'll
be good to see him I love him Spokane
Washington Spokane Comedy Club this
weekend Thursday Friday Saturday those
tickets are going fast uh Tacoma
Washington Tacoma Comedy Club September
29 September 30 October 1 Bridgeport
Connecticut Stress Factory October 13 14
15 and then we got Sean Bergen Charlotte
Illinois coming up yeah he's on the road
you have fun in Charlotte
it's lots of fun ones uh I'm in Boston
next week Boston next Thursday Friday
Saturday laugh Boston that is next week
we're almost sold out we might add some
shows but right now just one show
Thursday Two Friday two Saturday laugh
Boston Europe next week thick Boy tour
is coming to you then San Jose San Jose
Improv California October 13th through
the 15th just went on sale and then one
of my favorite clubs in the country Salt
Lake City Wise Guys October 20th through
22nd Calgary is October 27th that [ __ ]
almost sold out so we're gonna add a
show to that Friday on the 28th that's
at the Rooftop in downtown Calgary get
your tickets at thick boy.com the
tie-dye this tie-dye shirt we have this
in uh shirts the long shirts I always
Rock we have it in sweatshirts and
shorts this tide is dropping uh pretty
soon here so go to thickboy.com anything
with the whiskey go to thickboy.com as
well to get the tiger thick and order it
it will they deliver it right to your
crib you can get that thick boy.com
whiskey whatever you need merch all
right Tour tickets go to thickboy.com
that's it Brian went to go jack off to
Tim McGraw so he was not here right now
all right this is the fine kid we're out